>From earlier we developed this general equation where we use the coordinates of
2 points along a line to find the slope of that line. Now the coordinates of
home are (0,0) and the coordinates of the city Udacity on the map are (200,700),
not forgetting the scale of either axis. I'm going to pick the coordinates of
this point to be x2 and y2, and this one to be x1 and y1. Let's plug them in. We
have 700 minus 0 over 200 minus 0. Well that's pretty simple. It's just 700 over
200. If we cancel out a common factor of 100, we find that the slope of this
line is 7 over 2. Since Garrett really wants to know how to find out the
coordinates of any point along this route, we'll eventually want to incorporate
this slope into an equation for this line, but we're not there quite yet. Great
job on this really difficult lesson.